all right so i'm going to describe the
heat for you uh
it's going to be close to sizzling think
of putting that piece of
turkey bacon in the frying pan this
morning whatever it is you're cooking up
for breakfast
we do have some more heat coming our way
now yesterday we made it into the
mid-90s
and i think what people don't think
about is that when you're out in the hot
sun
it's another 10 to 15 degrees of heat on
your body so you think
i can handle the mid 90s but it's really
going to feel like 105 to 110
or hotter today with the hotter
temperatures coming lots of 70s
a few neighborhoods like the lakes
aliante centennial hills red rock in the
60s
here's what's going on for us we'll be
in those upper 90s close to 100 degrees
today the normal high
for this time in may is 88 so we're
definitely well above where we should be
weekend brings back winds and we'll look
for temperatures to drop into the low
80s by sunday best time to be watering
is really
before the sun comes up or after the sun
goes down
you know hector talking about those hot
cars
you roll up the windows you park in the
hot sun and you don't put in a sun shade
those temperatures can build at 20
degrees per hour inside that car
and within two to three hours you've got
temperatures inside your parked car
150 degrees or hotter when it's 100
degrees outside so
we're really facing a couple of hot days
here and it's really dangerous heat
for your cars that are parked out in the
sun high pressure is the reason for the
heat that will stay with us
for the next couple of days rain over
florida and again we're not getting
any rain for us here in the desert 98
officially but again north and east
valley neighborhoods
you're looking at reaching that century
mark today and tomorrow
and then southerly breezes tomorrow but
gustier winds i'm looking at
gusts that could reach 30 35 miles an
hour on saturday
if you've got outdoor plans but then a
cold front will bring us down to the 80s
low 80s sunday upper 80s monday back to
90s again next week